buenas tardes y el reino unido sigue en
su campaña de vacunación se han vacunado
cerca de 26 millones de personas en este
momento dando prioridad por supuesto a
los grupos más vulnerables y el gobierno
ha defendido también los expertos
continuar vacunando con esta medicina
desarrollada en territorio británico por
la universidad de oxford de la
prestigiosa universidad de oxford y
astrazéneca porque ofrece la seguridad y
también toda la protección que se
requiere contra el coronavirus hace
pocos minutos la vocera del gobierno ha
dicho en que el primer ministro mantiene
toda su confianza en la efectividad de
esta vacuna con la vacuna oxford
astrazéneca han sido inoculadas un poco
más de 11 millones de personas y los
casos reportados sobre estos coágulos
son muy bajos ha dicho no solamente el
departamento científico de este país
sino también la unión europea como ya lo
hemos escuchado y también la
organización mundial de la
que no hay evidencia científica
biológica que demuestre que hay esos
vínculos esos lazos entre la vacuna y
después desarrollar estos coágulos de
hecho esos mismos expertos han alertado
de los peligros de no vacunarse contra
el cob y teniendo disponibles las
vacunas frente a los posibles efectos
secundarios que pueden desarrollarse
también se ha dicho además que la vacuna
oxford astrazéneca ofrece muchas
ventajas sobre las otras vacunas y es
por ejemplo el precio esta cuesta apenas
tres dólares y también la logística es
mucho más sencilla dado que las vacunas
se pueden mantener a temperatura de una
nevera normal